ABHI YADAV: Thank you
all for joining us
on our talk today, in which we
take you through a deep dive
of Google Cloud's
IAM Recommender.
And we will walk
you through how Uber
was successful in
minimizing permissions
using this solution.
Sonal and the Uber team provided
us with valuable insights
during early stages.
And they'll be
sharing Uber's journey
and improving IAM for
the cloud in mind.
Hi, Sonal.
SONAL DESAI: Thank you, Abhi.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Sonal.
And I am a security
engineer at Uber.
I'm thrilled to be
here today to talk
about how IAM
Recommender helped us
identify a significant number
of over-granted permissions
in our GCP
infrastructure and helped
us bring closer to our goal
of achieving least privilege.
ABHI YADAV: OK,
let's get started.
So today, we're going to talk
a lot about IAM policies.
So let's first start
with a quick refresher
for those who might not be too
familiar with an anatomy of IAM
policy.
So policies as
shown here today are
a list of bindings
of rules to members.
Rules contain permissions.
And it can be referenced
once in the policy.
Members can include groups,
users, service accounts,
and more.
Here, things can
get a bit complex
if the group contains
nested group as members.
The policy also
contains an audit config
that determines which
permission types are logged.
A policy document is attached
or applied at a resource.
For example, it can be
applied on a project
and then inherits downward all
the resources in that project.
So effective access for
a member is a combination
of the roles in this
policy and a union
of all of those inherited from
above, like from a folder.
Now, policy evaluation always
traverses the hierarchy tree
downward.
This is why in some cases,
managing project-level policies
is recommended.
Lastly, remember that setting
policy programmatically
replaces any existing
policy on the resource.
So think about it as a whole,
and not just the delta,
to avoid removing any old
content that was already there.
Now, assuming you
understand that well,
let's think about
whether your policies are
constructed accurately to
reduce security risk exposure.
Ideally, you want to reach
a state of least privilege,
where you limit
the attack surface
by granting users only the
access or the permissions
they need.
But we found that, when
it comes to risk exposure,
people tend to underestimate
the risk they are in.
It's only human nature.
And while digging
into this problem
space with our customers,
we found that consistently,
across the board, admins were
granting way more permissions
than the users needed.
One reason was to
ensure that developers
could do what they want,
but also because changing
policies is complex and they
didn't want to break anything.
But this exposes them to risk.
So we heard our
customers ask for tooling
to understand this
risk and help them
get towards a state
of least privilege.
Another big problem in the
cloud is human misconfiguration.
So what was needed was some
advanced tools that admins
can turn on for the end
users to detect bad policies,
self-diagnosis in a way,
that goes a long way
to give admins the
power to say it's
not only up to the
individual project teams,
but I'm going to check for
these bad things as well.
So if you're a security
professional who's
concerned about this, here
is some prescriptive guidance
from Google on how you should
think about getting to least
privilege.
As with most things,
start with the why.
First, understand
how much access
is provisioned across
your production workloads.
To initiate any kind
of policy cleanup,
you will first need
data that's compelling
and based on actual usage.
Then tie that clean-up back
to organization's goals,
like containing insider risk,
which is one of the leading
causes of breaches and fines.
And aim towards educating
your project team
so they are better aware
of their risk posture
and they are driving
towards cultural change.
Then, as you are ready
to start taking action,
create a phase plan that starts
with reducing permissions
to other safer baseline.
Most customers opt to do
a quarterly access review.
And then for high privilege
roles like owner and editor,
we recommend a
higher cadence, which
could be on a daily basis.
Lastly, you can also
prioritize based on the member.
So you should pay attention
to service accounts,
maybe start there.
And to reduce grants
and service accounts,
and especially look for
service account impersonation
permissions if they are not
needed for individual members.
Also, look for dormant users who
might be orphaned but present
in your policies.
And lastly, in terms of who does
this, we feel in order for this
to be successful with
the right tooling,
least privilege should be the
responsibility of all project
teams, and not just
security professionals.
So here's where IAM
Recommender comes in.
It helps security and
nonsecurity professionals
identify and remove
unwanted access
to GCP by using machine learning
to make smart access control
recommendations.
Right here in the IAM
page, the Recommender
is going to show you how many
permissions you have given
and what is actually being used.
There's no need to collect
and parse through access logs.
We've done all that
hard work for you.
In the back-end, we store
and process petabytes of data
on a daily basis.
All of this is at no additional
charge to our customers.
We now simply show
you this information,
show you this compelling
data, right next
to the user's assigned role.
Now, it looks like most
of the users in my project
here are OK.
And a few of them
are using a lot less
than they were granted.
You will see here that three
light bulbs have popped up.
This is where our
ML models have found
a recommendation for a better
fitting role automatically
in the background.
I've had to do no work.
The service account
here on the top row
has the owner role, with
about 1,800 permissions
but is only using
31 out of them.
So here, IAM
Recommender shows me
that I must change its role
to reduce security risk.
Now, if I'm
interested in details,
I can double-click and
get some more analysis
behind the recommendation.
So here, the tool is showing me
that the service account should
be moved to the
BigQuery admin role
and why by highlighting
the permissions
that are safe to remove in red.
ML also picks up
that this account
will need the saved
queries update
permission in the future based
on similar usage patterns.
Now, this is a
permission it already has
but it has not used.
And you can find this
marked with the blue ML
icon everywhere in the
[INAUDIBLE] [? console. ?]
So this helps make sure that
this user or account does not
miss out on permissions
and you don't need to come
back later to request more.
And now, in our
latest update, we
have also added
the ability for you
to customize the recommendation.
So if you want to remove
a permission or add one,
you can do that right
here in the recommendation
screen in context, which
creates a custom role.
And now this custom
role would be
based on actual activity data
and improved with Google ML
to suggest which permissions you
should have based on observed
patterns in the Cloud.
So as a user, you just need to
hit Apply to make the change.
And this custom
role gets created.
And now it should be
recommended to other users who
have the similar need.
Now Uber has taken some
really innovative steps
with our recommendations.
And they've integrated this
into their security automation
pipeline.
So now to take you through
that journey, Sonal,
we'd love to
understand what you've
done with our recommendations.
SONAL DESAI: Thank you, Abhi.
Uber has a tripod strategy
for infrastructure.
We maintain on-premise and we
have a presence in AWS and GCP.
In GCP, we are a
large-scale shop.
You can see we have 90,000
role bindings alone.
Our cloud security team is
responsible for security
in AWS and GCP.
Our team's mission is to
enable our partner teams, which
are our business teams,
to conduct business
as usual and leverage cloud
in a secure and efficient way.
We are entrusted with functions
like inventory management,
asset management,
roles granting,
and provisioning in the cloud.
At Uber, we would like
builders to build.
With the above
functions in mind,
we would like to strike a
balance between our partner
teams and the security team.
And it is hard to do
because partner teams want
ease of allocating
resources in the cloud.
They want ease of
maintaining their resources.
And we want to encourage
ownership in them.
As a cloud team, we
would like our eyes
to be on our cloud
infrastructure.
We would like to remediate
over-granted permissions,
and overall maintain
least privilege.
And by that, I mean
reduce our attack surface
and apply permissions as needed.
So let's focus on
over-granted permissions.
Over-provisioning can
lead to data breaches.
For example, an identity
that has high privilege role
gets compromised and is
used to access PCI PII data.
This is data with high level of
data classification as needed
by compliance.
This can lead to
severe problems.
It is a real-world example
and we have seen it before.
It is quite common.
Asking engineers to
choose a more nuanced role
is confusing to them.
They often resort in picking
up editor or owner rules
because it gets the work done.
So then what is our
approach to least privilege?
We would like to
monitor our footprint.
What are our cloud assets?
What are our identities?
How many roles are
for those identities?
We have targeted
use cases in mind.
For example, service account
with primitive roles,
with each of this
roles having more
than 2,500 permissions,
same for user
accounts and Google Groups.
Then we have the
orphaned accounts.
For example, a co-worker
has left the company.
And in Uber's case,
the account needs
to be cleaned up
in GCP environment.
Then there are the older,
unused permissions.
These are not used by anybody.
They are simply lying
around, unacknowledged.
We would like to clean them up.
With this, we have
two solutions in mind.
One is create a ticket
for the partner teams
simply because we do not
have enough business context.
In the ticket, we'll
provide enough information
of why the ticket is generated
and how to go about fixing it.
The second one is to auto
apply the recommendation
by the security team itself.
And it should be done
in an automated way.
So with the least
privilege in mind,
we would like our
recommendations
to be data-backed.
In our experience with the
previous cloud provider,
we found that we have
to manually write
scripts to find out
the activity log,
data mine the access
pattern, and then
put the data into
sheet, and then
go through each of
the data manually,
and try to remediate
the recommendation.
It often leads to
problems like access
denied because there is
no other intelligence
for the recommendation than
simply the access traffic.
Enter GCP IAM Recommender,
with all the bells and whistles
of being based on
historical activity logs
and being backed by ML, wherein
it predicts if a role might
be needed in near future.
We do not have to
pay for the logs
because IAM Recommender
does all the heavy lifting
of collecting, storing,
and analyzing logs.
It is also API-driven,
which makes
it possible to automate and
make it a repeatable process.
So what is our solution?
This is a very
high level overview
of how we have automated
IAM Recommender.
The major components
are manager--
manager runs periodically
to get recommendations
from IAM recommended API.
It simplifies the
recommendations
to be used internally and then
stores it into a database.
It then invokes an action.
Action is a rules-based engine.
It determines what
should be the remediation
step for the recommendation
and it also prioritizes.
Because we have
hundreds of projects
and we have hundreds
of recommendations
for each of those projects,
it was important for us
to prioritize the
recommendation.
And hence, we introduced
the concept of risk coding.
Our risk coding is
based on two steps.
First, business rules-- we
started with the NIST framework
and then we created
our own business rules
based on the tech and
business priorities.
For example, a project that
has on-premise connectivity
or a project that has data
classification levels of PCI,
PII, all the recommendations
for that project
will be marked with
higher priority.
The second is access type.
Access type is based on
the number of permissions
and whether the type of
access is edit and delete.
It will have higher priority
than, say, a view-only role.
The third step is remediate.
The remediation could
either be create a ticket
for the partner
team, in which case
we'll create a [? GR ?] ticket.
Or it could be auto applying
the recommendation, which
is an automated way
that the pipeline kicks
in and auto-remediates.
So now let's look into
the detail architecture.
We wanted to make the
architecture serverless
and event driven based on
Cloud functions and Pub/Sub,
so as to make it scalable and
extensible to future use cases.
The first step is to
get the recommendations.
We spoke about
[? how ?] the manager,
which is a Cloud Function.
And before I delve
into the detail,
we talked about the serverless,
event-driven architecture
based on Cloud
Functions and Pub/Sub,
so as to make it
scalable and extensible
for future use cases.
[? So ?] a manager, which
is a Cloud Function, runs
periodically, in our
case on a daily basis.
[INAUDIBLE] IAM Recommender
API [? patches ?]
the recommendations and
stores it in a FireStore DB.
The reason we chose FireStore
is because it's easy to use
and we needed a NoSQL
solution [INAUDIBLE]
extensibility of
the schema in mind.
So then the second
floor is where,
using data transfer jobs,
we get recommendations
from IAM Recommender and
stored it into the BigQuery.
BigQuery allows us to have
a single pane of glass
that we could see all the
permissions across Uber are.
The second component in
the first step is Enricher.
It has two main functions.
It gets project details
from Resource Manager.
And the project
details could be who
is the owner of the
project, or what was
the create time of the project.
And the second details
it gets is from G Suite.
And it gets details about the
active employees in the company
right now.
This is needed for
the orphan use case.
All these details are
stored in FireStore DB.
Then step two is
where the manager
invokes an action via Pub/Sub.
What is the action doing?
The action [INAUDIBLE] the
recommendation and determines
what is the next step, or
what is the right remediation,
to apply to that recommendation.
It also decides
what is the priority
and the risk [? call. ?]
So that is where we do
prioritizing and actioning
on each recommendation
in the FireStore DB.
Once this is done, we move on to
step three, which is remediate.
So in step three, if
it is a create a ticket
type of recommendation,
then the action
invokes an internal service.
The internal services reads the
details of the recommendation
from FireStore DB and
creates a [? GR ?] ticket.
If it's an auto apply
type of recommendation,
then the action invokes
remediator, which
is basically a cloud function.
And the remediator reads the
details from FireStore DB,
and it does then two steps.
One, it calls IAM Recommender
to claim the recommendation.
And second, it calls Cloud IAM
to apply that recommendation
and mark it successful.
Please note, like
we said before,
apply the entire recommendation
as a whole policy,
and not just a
specific role binding.
Now, I would love to show
you how we have built it.
This is the Cloud Console
where our project teams can
go and see what
are the IAM roles
and what are the
recommendations.
For example, the first
one that you can see
is a service icon
account for compute.
And it's been assigned
an editor role.
And that is an icon
from IAM Recommender
to suggest there is a
recommendation for it.
Next, our step
one has kicked in.
And the manager calls
IAM Recommender API
to get payload about
the recommendations.
This is what a typical
payload looks like.
As you can see, there are
two actions being suggested.
One is to remove the role.
And one is to add a role.
Also note, there
is an E tag, which
we use for concurrency
and versioning control.
Each time there is an
update to a recommendation,
a new E tag is generated.
Now comes step two.
This is where the manager has
simplified the recommendation
for internal use.
You can very clearly
see the action
is to remove the editor
role and to add a smaller
Dataproc worker role.
And you can see the action has
also given us a [? reality, ?]
which is medium, and a risk
[? course. ?] So we have
prioritized it.
Now, the action has determined
this particular case
is for create a ticket
type remediation.
And that's why a [? GR ?]
ticket is created.
This is a sample ticket here.
But some things to
note, the ticket
is assigned to
the project owner.
In this case, it is me
because I own the project.
We also include a resource
link so that project owners
can directly click
on the link and go
to GCP Console, where they can
see the actual recommendation.
Then we have the
description, wherein
we note why this
ticket was generated
and how to go about fixing
it with detailed screenshots
and steps.
There is also a security level
and order priority level.
Coming to step three, this
is where a project owner
can go in the Cloud Console
and apply the remediation.
You can see from
our previous steps
this is the same service
account for compute example.
The recommendation
is applied and now,
instead of editor role, it
has the Dataproc worker role,
and there is no IAM Recommender
sign of [INAUDIBLE]..
So lessons learned--
as with any product,
it is important to spend
time upfront in understanding
the APIs and trust
the recommendations
or trust the data.
Our technical
design and approach
came about from the
proof of concept
we did right in the beginning.
It was very easy to auto-apply
all the recommendations we got.
But then we found
that there were
edge cases like backups or
break glass accounts, where
we needed manual intervention.
Learning the landscape--
we knew we had a problem
with over-granted permissions.
But we did not know how
severe the problem was.
BigQuery and data
transfer jobs helped
us get a cross-project
overview across the arc
and understand
our IAM footprint.
[INAUDIBLE] with a better
understanding of our IAM
status, it solidified our intent
in going after our IAM access
and using IAM Recommender.
And finally, being
early adopters,
we got stuck at times.
Here, we were able to leverage
our partnership with Google
in terms of technical expertise
and product assistance.
It was a great overall
learning experience.
And Google was an
awesome partner.
Thank you.
ABHI YADAV: Thank you, Sonal.
I'm so happy to hear that
and share your story.
Super excited about customers
like Uber and thousands
more who are using IAM
Recommender every day
to minimize their attack
surface and achieve least
privileged with least effort.
We introduced this
product last year at Next
to provide AI for
cloud governance.
And since then, we have launched
several new and interesting
features.
First, we have made policy
utilization data more readily
accessible with IAM Insights.
This lets you build
custom reports
or integrate recommendations
into your governance tools.
Second, we now
support recommendation
of multiple granular roles to
help you migrate off legacy
roles like owner and editor.
Next, we have expanded our
analysis and recommendations
to groups.
So what we will now tell you,
if a group is over-provisioned
and what role to assign it.
Lastly, we not recommend
creation of custom roles
where, if you find
that a custom role can
be used across your projects to
reduce over-granting of access,
we take you through the steps
of creating that custom role.
And we have many more
features in development
that our customers are
pretty excited about.
Another area we have invested
in is making recommendations
easier to discover.
We felt this is an area that
needed much more investment.
Now project teams can
self-serve in the Cloud Console
in the IAM page, as
you have seen already.
And now they're also able
to find recommendations
in a recommendation hub that
is located on the Cloud Console
dashboard.
Here, project teams
can review the insights
and recommendations
and apply them
if they have the permission.
For central security teams,
we now support out-of-the-box
integration with BigQuery.
With a few simple steps, you can
export all your recommendations
to a BigQuery table.
And this would allow you to
create org-wide custom reports.
For example, if you want
a view of all provisioning
across the production
workloads, or analyze
permissions for a
given service account,
you can now do this easily
without analytical tools.
Lastly, we exposed insights and
recommendations through APIs
with methods such as Get,
Claim, Mark as Succeeded.
So in addition to
automating recommendations,
as we heard Uber describe
today, some customers
have used this to create
alerts and reminders
such as weekly digests that
they send their project
teams to alert them they
need to take action.
We hope you've
enjoyed this deep dive
into IAM Recommender today.
We are excited to
announce that Recommender
is a part of Active Assist, a
brand new solution from Google
Cloud that we've just announced.
Active Assist is a
new solution that
focuses on reducing complexity
in your cloud environment
by providing you with a variety
of intelligent and proactive
features, many of which are
powered by machine learning.
By using the capabilities
within Active Assist,
you are empowered to focus more
of your time on your business
and less on cloud
administration.
By using the intelligent
capabilities of Active Assist,
it makes it really
easy and efficient
for your teams to do
their jobs, especially
with things like finding
out what went wrong quickly
so you can take action right
away with insightful, effective
troubleshooting tools.
Secondly, preventing mistakes
from happening altogether
by relying on analysis
tools before you
can make the changes.
And lastly, as we saw today,
improving your cloud easily
with fast, actionable
recommendations
with clear rationales for why.
To get started
with Active Assist,
we encourage you to
visit the website
and go over to Cloud Console,
to the recommendation
hub on the IAM page, and see if
there are any recommendations
there waiting for you.
Some of the features
we highlighted
are only available
in preview today.
But if you are interested in
getting early access to all
of these features as they get
developed and give us feedback,
we encourage you to join
our Insider Group, which
is linked on our website.
And finally, check out these
other Cloud OnAir sessions
for deeper dive into
some of these features.
Thank you for your time.
We hope you enjoyed
our session today.
And happy IAMing.